how sup guys my name is Asher now and
welcome to the second episode of the
Sparky gaming series in which we make a
game engine from scratch in C++ and
OpenGL so last episode we created this
awesome window if you want to catch up
with the code or whatever it'll be on
github there'll be a link in the
description to all of the source code so
you can either watch the first episode
which I recommend or you can just
download the source code but the point
is this is where we stopped right we had
a we draw we drew a rectangle it was
just a lovely white rectangle we can
resize the window and it will properly
resize and we loaded in GL FW which
would be our opengl framework kind of
library which is just in charge of
events such as well what I mean women
putting conflicts again Lowell anyway
which is going to be in charge of stuff
like events so keyboard events Mouse
events all that stuff as well as
actually giving us this wonderful window
which we created in the window CBP file
right so that's what we did last episode
that's a quick recap if you haven't
watched it go watch it this episode
we're going to be loading glue so GL e w
or opengl extension wrangle in fact I
can just google this because I'm going
to have to download it anyway over here
it so it's over here right this is
essentially needed for loading
extensions so the idea is Windows only
gives us opengl 1.1 right if we want to
use a version above that because clearly
our graphics cards support versions
above 1.1 you know for example my one
supports 4.5 in order to use those later
what versions and all of the like all of
the new functions that come with these
later versions we need to actually load
them in because the windows doesn't do
it for us so we need something like this
which will simply load in the functions
from our graphics card drivers and call
them when we so we need function
pointers to OpenGL functions essentially
glue does just that which is perfect
because it would take a really like it
will take quite a while for us to write
the equivalent because literally all
this library does is it simply it
literally just retrouver it it just
retrieves like function pointers to
pretty much every opengl function there
is up to 4.5 which is awesome
so to get this we're just going to use
the Brigham Paul binaries so we'll get
the binaries for Windows which is
awesome now this is available for Linux
and Mac I believe but I don't think the
binaries are available or at least well
it wasn't on this front page so it might
be somewhere else you might have to
build it yourself I don't know we're on
Windows so we're getting that way for
this to download and there we go alright
cool so here's a downloaded thing again
I'm going to take this I'm going to put
it into my libs folder this is just for
our extracted files and now we've got
glue in here so in here we've got a
bunch of cool stuff so we've got the Lib
that we want if you go into relay I
don't even know what release MX is
honestly but under release and win32 is
what we want alright so and we want the
so if you again I'm assuming that the s
is the static library version so if you
want glue to get compiled into your or
linked into your Exe file you can use s
otherwise if you want to use a separate
lab and dll file you can use the first
one here and then you can go back into
bin and you'll have to put glue 32 dll
into your actual directory for XE right
where par we're going to do the former
because honestly we might as well
compile I'll link glue into our XE so
all we'll need is this right so let's
copy that let's take it into Visual
Studio Projects and Sparky and then
under Sparky we'll have dependencies and
then I'm going to make a folder called
glue all right and on the glue we're
going to make a folder called Lib so
we'll be nice and organized and then
there's our loop file and then we'll
also make a folder of course called
include and then I'll go back to
documents into libs glue I'll grab the
include folder or rather I'll just the
GL folder inside it and it one more file
a moment directory and then I'll just
paste it into here so these are all the
headers which we need obviously to
actually call the functions so that's
our app let's let's party so first of
all I'm going to right-click on my
project hit properties make sure I'm in
the right configuration so debug in this
case we can probably put this under all
configurations as well leave it in debug
for now low invasive plus what
directories I'm going to add the include
directory right I'll add a new one being
this this glue include directory again
I'll make it relative to the solution so
we just need to change literally one
letter there from after II hit OK on
that and then library directories I'm
going to do a similar thing change that
one letter from F to E ok and then all I
need to do in the linker and input is
add in glue 32s lib so I'm guessing the
S stands for static ok ok so now I mean
there's nothing to build but hopefully
we just don't get any errors flat out oh
we do so cannot open file glue 32s lib
let's make sure that is in there lib
glue 32s I'll live alright let's just
check that directory again I think I
might've I didn't really pay too much
attention to the directory i just copied
and pasted it so let's make sure that
our library directory is set correctly
okay it's not so make sure you let's
remove this Lib VC 2013 part of it hit
OK ok and now fantastic none of that so
I've probably somehow gotten ah that's
probably cuz glue was already mmm
actually okay let's go back to to fix
this warning not that it's too deadly or
anything but we should fix it it's
conflicting with another library so I've
probably got something like C it doesn't
look like I do though we've probably got
something in here that's being used hmm
oh the MS VCR t1 so where else is this
included in so this is conflicting with
another library of the same name and I
don't even know where because the only
ones we've changed I believe are as in
the only ones we've set
into our dependencies right
what other library directories do we
have once we don't have anything in
additional no we don't okay
library path hmm that's weird that is
quite weird so we've got maybe both of
these contain it I don't know anyway
ignoring that let's go ahead and okay so
it builds and it opens up the the file
so that's basically what we're
interested in can find the library so
now let's actually instantiate this or
initialize it I should say in window dot
H I got to stop trying to do that
because of the FaceCam but I'll go ahead
and include a GL / glue so the good
thing about this is this header file if
I actually go to it open document right
this is the actual header file and its
massive it's like nineteen thousand
lines and all of it is are just like
function pointers but R and stuff like
you know constants and all those nice
defines but the point is if you look at
this this is basically everything for
OpenGL in fact I think it even has stuff
like yes it even has like OpenGL 1.1
stuff yeah which gets defined and
everything so it's got everything we
need so we no longer need g lr w for
that in fact it might even give us an
error because something is included
before it's supposed to be we'll see but
that's really what we need so once we've
included glue into our window H we want
to actually initialize glue so glue
needs to be initialized in a very limits
just turn off all these intellisense
arrows a rubbish what we need to do is
initialize glue the exact pretty much
the exact same way the GLB gets
initialized now of course we want to
check for an arrow and everything so
once we make our context make sure you
do this after a context exists if you
try and make this before you actually
create the gfw stuff you're it's not
going to work okay and you'll probably
cry so now I'm probably demonstrate that
in a minute actually not the crying part
but if we go ahead and say something
like glue in
right and the way we check an error code
is essentially there's something called
glue underscore okay so if glue in it
our equals
I'm sorry doesn't equal glue okay right
it means that glue is not okay and
something went wrong
so we'll do our return false again and
we'll we'll just print out something
like could not initialize Lowell typing
glue whether with a nice exclamation
mark at the end there to let everyone
know that it that I mean business so
okay so see for example this GL dot H
was included before blue
now what included GL dot H that would
have been included by J left I'll be so
let's just simply move these if you hold
down alt and just the up arrow you can
move individual lines like that
hit ctrl s and let's rebuild us again
and as you can see we shouldn't get any
errors bottom line result externals
which is fantastic so looks like it
can't load our library let's go back
into this alright so this is to find the
gate cool we're in the header file
alright time to investigate this library
and let's see library directories let's
make sure that's correct their pits had
even right glue Lib it is we 32s Lib and
I mean surely it would have complained
though mmm-hmm let's try the other web
file so let's try the other wonderful
Lib file we've supplied we've been
supplied like this one and see if that
works maybe I was wrong about as you me
know that was let's just try this
okay that worked I don't know maybe
that's interesting I would have liked to
use the static one unless I was wrong
about it I don't know don't know so well
I guess what we won't use the static one
for now I'll see if I can find a fixed
before next episode but glue 32 dot lab
is what will include instead of glue 32
a stat Lib so make sure you copy that
make sure you copy that
just the without the S part onto your
your Lib directory so that you can
actually I'll keep the s in there for
now
this unfortunately does mean well
neither DLL file unfortunately so if
yeah if I do build this but I try and
run it it'll complain about glue 32
don't DLL is missing so what you want to
do is put that into the right directory
one thing I'm going to do today as well
oh I need the appropriate define see
this is why live-streaming is just
fantastic so let's go ahead and that
that's just ridiculous okay so let's try
the changes to blue 32 estaat Lib and
then over in C++ preprocessor I'm going
to add a preprocessor definition called
blue on the score static okay so if I do
that let me just test out make sure this
works first it works okay cool so that's
that's great okay so just to go into
more detail because I wanted to see if
it worked first before I explain
everything so what I did was so we're
back to using our glue 32s table which
means we do not need the DLL so we're
using s and then over in C++
preprocessor to use the static to use
the static library we need to actually
define a little flag called glue static
okay and I'm assuming that will just
that'll yeah that will change how
they'll probably be something in the
header file let's let's see if we can
find it out of curiosity
yep so you can see that if glue static
is defined it'll call externalise it'll
call our little decals backwards dll
export which will actually essentially
require a dll file so that's the awesome
idea okay so if glue static is defined
again it will do that rather than this
which is good because we don't want it
to access the we don't want it to export
it to the DLL file because we don't want
to do elf file cool
so without set we shouldn't need that
dll file at all so if we run this now we
should get our window and we shouldn't
get any error message as being like glue
could not be initialized so now glue is
running and everything is fantastic
now do we need to terminate glue I don't
know I'm just gonna ask you guys in the
chat right now I don't think we do in
fact we can probably just check the
header file there anything here about
terminate no not really
so all this is called destroy or
something I'm just going to assume it
doesn't exist so that being said we
should now have OpenGL like modern
version II running okay so let's see so
what one thing I'll do in window is once
all this stuff gets done um oh and let
me quickly demonstrate the crying part
that I was talking about if we grab glue
in it and we put it up before we make
the context and whatnot glue will
probably fail and as you can see it says
could not initialize a glue so make sure
this is after we actually make this
context otherwise it will not work
alright so back down you go cool so
let's quickly print out the version of
OpenGL we're on so I'll just print
opengl and then we did this last time
but I actually want to be continually
printing this so GL get string
gl version alright so I'll just do this
at the end not that it matters it's just
that if blue fails I don't want to print
out our OpenGL version right so we want
to return false and not print this out
because that'll give the illusion that
everything is good but it's not so over
4.5 great that was the same without glue
so we need to actually test glue by
running an OpenGL method that is above
1.1 which is like 95% of them so let's
go ahead and do that what I'll do is
I'll simply I'll just do something like
I'll make and we'll make a V a oh this
this this won't even render but it will
it'll it'll it'll be sufficient for our
test so if I Jen vertex arrays that's
something in opengl 3.0 we'll probably
want one and of course this is not how
you do it law I'm thinking in like Java
LW jgl land so let's do that yeah so
we're generating a vertex array and
we'll get onto that stuff in the future
of course it's way too early to talk
about that will bind this vertex array
and then we will we won't do this well
I've tried to comment it out but it
didn't want to be okay we'll just shut
that off for now and then all I'll do is
I'll just jail like draw arrays law
would rule 0 I'll probably fail there
anyway let's just try to do something
like that and if we run it hopefully we
get no errors
okay so there's no errors it's running
its drawing stuff we don't even have any
shaders so it doesn't know what to draw
anyway the it's just mayhem but it works
and we're not getting any errors so I
think this is good enough to demonstrate
the glue is loaded correctly because
again this stuff is modern OpenGL which
is in like OpenGL 3 and not in the
default 1.1 that we get so that being
said everything is just the best now so
we can probably the one thing I wanted
to do in this episode that I thought you
know well let's do that
but I don't remember what it
let's think did I mention anything
stream
did I mention anything that I was like I
want to do this today because we've got
a bit of extra time or something it was
something there was definitely something
but I don't know I didn't remember what
it was so rescue me stream let me just
go through this go quickly so loving
nothing nothing that's all good
we had our stuff done I honestly don't
know I think I've covered everything I
wanted to cover yes me no okay so I
guess we're going to end the episode
here what we're going to do tomorrow and
this actually won't be tomorrow but in
the next few days what we're going to do
next episode I should say is probably
move on to input so we'll cover some GL
fw input so how we can handle input such
as keyboard and mouse will probably make
a nice class for that as well and apart
from that we'll just will go with the
flow so that's it
if you have any questions as usual just
post them in the comments below I'll try
and get to the next episode i'll
probably just answer some just in the
YouTube chat as well and yeah and we'll
move on
so I'll commit this to oh no I
remembered what I wanted to do almost
something oh yeah I wanted to set up our
yes you guys are lucky because I just
remember this before I stopped the video
I wanted to set up a nice output
directory because right now if we look
at this oh you guys are so lucky right
now if we look at this this just next
like half of our intermediates go to
like this debug directory then our
actual stuff goes into this debug
directory and it's just mayhem so what I
want to have is just normal bin
directory which has all of our binaries
out here ok so to do that right I'll
right-click on Sparky core hit
properties will go all the way into
general which is just at the top here
under configuration properties and then
what we're going to be looking for is
but director any intermediate directory
so what we'll do is we'll and what are
you guys type in caps for right anyway
so once we're in this general we want to
take a look at output directory and
intermediate directory output directory
we'll probably set equal to so solution
directory which is going to be this
because it's the directory of the
solution file that we have right whoops
right here we want to make a folder
called bin so we'll just type in bin
stands for binaries inside there I'm
going to put probably what we had before
which is configuration so basically I'll
just put bin backslash configuration so
configuration is basically what you see
up here debug will release anything we
want to have that stuff there okay
intermediate directory I want to put in
to essentially the same directory is
there so I want to put it into solution
directory bin configuration and then
intermediates just like that
again this is just my kind of preference
it doesn't matter what you guys decide
to do but it's really up to you but
we're going to do it this way so yeah so
if we just hit OK on that and we try and
build this let me just see if we didn't
get any
we didn't so sometimes it will hang
intermediate directories don't end with
the trailing slash so let's go back here
and add a trailing slash just in case we
decide to use it somewhere else so hit
OK and build out that warning should go
away I did we actually can get any
warnings so you can see that we now go
to bin folder with debug and then
intermediates are in there and
everything's good and we don't need to
have these disastrous like these folders
here everywhere I don't like having that
around so I'm just going to do that okay
cool so if we build this again or
whatever well that's not going to build
again because it already built but
inside here is spiky cord or exe which
is our lovely thing cool so what I'll do
quickly is
restore peace by just switching that
back home so we actually do get
something rendering but that is pretty
much it so I'm just gonna push this too
to github so any questions leave them
below and the next steps that we'll move
on to input handling in let's just see
if we can move around that beautiful
square of ours okay all rectangle
actually is what it is thanks for
watching and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
you